tremendo me parece que es estamos
hablando del mayor fichaje en la
historia de la liga mx femenil pero
también incluso se puede comparar con la
liga mx varonil por ahí incluso había
una serie de comparaciones de los
fichajes bombas que se han hecho en el
fútbol mexicano y este me parece que es
uno de los que ya van a pasar
a la historia a ver la liga femenil
aprecido aqui en mexico las estructuras
los equipos y poco a poco le han
apostado a la liga femenil y este es el
y clarísimo ejemplo hoy pachuca no
solamente busca ser protagonista aquí en
méxico también busca la
internacionalización y creo que eso es
también uno de los objetivos que busca
la liga mx femenil lo está haciendo en
diferentes clubes y me parece que es
decir es sin duda alguna un fichaje o
una bomba como yo incluso lo manejan y
redes sociales un hermoso bombazo porque
le viene a bien a la liga en x-men y lo
que le ha apostado en
e insisto a su estructura al nivel no
sabemos también qué condiciones viene
jennifer me parece que también hay anda
un poco lesionado ojalá que se pueda
recuperar al cien porque evidentemente
la queremos ver explotar su nivel al
máximo pero a ver estamos haciendo este
enlace no méxico allá en colombia pero
tú ves las redes sociales tú ves las
noticias douglas y la liga mx femenil
está dando de qué hablar y me parece que
eso es un magnífico
fichaje un gran paso por supuesto para
que méxico también se internacionalice
en el fútbol femenino bueno del pachuca
particularmente se refuerza y de gran
manera para este campeonato vienen de
perder la final y ya cuentan en sus
filas con charlyn corral una gran
delantera que también militó así que
terminan con un gran ataque las cosas
totalmente se conocen charlyn corral que
está pasando por un grandísimo momento
también llegó lesionada aquí cuando
regresó al fútbol mexicano pero poco a
poco ha reformado un grandísimo nivel
una de las goleadoras históricas en el
fútbol mexicano con las elecciones y
bueno ahora imagínate ver las juntas en
un mismo club jennifer con charlyn
corral me parece que va a ser estupendo
que busca pachuca pues el título algo
que se le ha negado bien lo comentó se
acaba de perder la final contra contra
las chivas y me parece que les hacía
falta este grandísimo elemento pachuca
busca eso busca primero el título y
también expandir sus horizontes ahora
que ya la liga mx femenil permite más de
tres extranjeras ser cuatro extranjeras
pero me parece que este es un grandísimo
ejemplo que está poniendo el conjunto de
las cosas ojalá que así lo consigan
porque bueno me parece que es una gran
inversión una gran apuesta y también me
mostrarle no solamente el fútbol
mexicano sino al mundo que hay que
apostarle y hay que también creer en el
fútbol femenil así que cuando las tusas
vásquez reforzadas esperando a ver en
grandísimo nivel ambas goleadoras a
charlyn corral
por supuesto hay un yermo